The Game of Thrones epic prequel series, House
of the Dragon, is coming and many epic characters
with it as well, from Targaryens to many other
houses and many other legendary figures from
that time period as well.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Filming begins with the start of 2021.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It’s based on George RR Martin’s book
Fire And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s
yet unfinished Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
That's Fire And Blood volume 1.
The yet unreleased Fire And Vlood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
The key event of the show is also the key
in the history of House Targaryen, the Dance
of the Dragons - the Targaryen civil war,
which divided the entire kingdom and launched
a huge war that was fought from 129 AC to
131 AC. When King Viserys died, his oldest
child, Rhaenyra, was expected to ascend the
Iron Throne, since her father did not change
the succession when he had a son Aegon. However,
Aegon II Targaryen was crowned King in the
Dragonpit, at bequest of Alicent Hightower.
The war between brother and sister would be
known as the Dance of the Dragons.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
Both of them thought they belonged on the
Iron Throne. When people started declaring
for one of them or the other, their fight
divided the kingdoms in two.
Targaryens fought Targaryens, bothers fought
brothers, dragons fought dragons. By the time
it was over, thousands were dead.
The conflict would prove to be incredibly
destructive for not only House Targaryen,
but large parts of Westeros as well. In addition,
it devastated the Targaryen's dragon population,
ultimately leading to their extinction within
a few decades.
By the end of the reign of King Viserys I
Targaryen, twenty dragons were alive. The
majority of these died during the civil war
called the Dance of the Dragons, which began
in 129 AC and lasted until mid 131 AC.
One of the main characters from this time
period was Rhaenys Targaryen, Rhaenyra's right
hand.
Princess Rhaenys Targaryen, known among the
smallfolk as the Queen Who Never Was, was
the daughter of Prince Aemon Targaryen and
Lady Jocelyn Baratheon born in 74 AC on the
seventh day of the seventh month. Rhaenys
Targaryen was the granddaughter of Jaehaerys
I Targaryen, and the cousin of Viserys I Targaryen
and Daemon Targaryen. Rhaenys was a great
beauty.
She was a clever, capable, spirited, proud,
fierce and fearless woman. She had a fiery
temperament.
Rhaenys wore steel and copper armor which
flashed on the sun. As her father was the
Prince of Dragonstone, and she was his firstborn
child, many considered her as being next in
line for the Iron Throne, after her father
Aemon. Queen Alysanne Targaryen, when being
presented with her granddaughter, called her
"our queen to be". Rhaenys became a dragonrider
in 87 AC when she claimed the dragon Meleys,
the Red Queen. Rhaenys married legendary Corlys
of House Velaryion, known as the Sea Snake,
in 90 AC at the age of sixteen. Rhaenys's
father, Prince Aemon Targaryen, died in 92
AC.
As Aemon had been the Prince of Dragonstone,
King Jaehaerys I Targaryen had to formally
appoint a new heir to the Iron Throne. The
choice was between Rhaenys, Aemon's only child
and heir, and Aemon's brother Baelon. Jaehaerys
appointed Baelon as the new Prince of Dragonstone,
passing over the pregnant Rhaenys and her
unborn child. Rhaenys herself was the first
to object to the king's decision, and her
husband, Lord Corlys Velaryon, gave up his
position as lord admiral and his place on
the small council. Following that, Rhaenys
and her husband returned to Driftmark. Others
angered by the king's decision included Rhaenys's
mother, Lady Jocelyn Baratheon, her uncle,
Lord Boremund Baratheon, and her grandmother,
King Jaehaerys's wife, Queen Alysanne Targaryen.
Rhaenys gave birth to her first child, a daughter
she named Laena Velaryon, late in the year
92 AC.
The following year, she gave birth to a son,
Laenor Velaryon. Although both House Velaryon
and House Baratheon insisted that Laenor had
the better claim to the throne, Prince Baelon
remained King Jaehaerys's heir.
When Baelon died in 101 AC, King Jaehaerys
called the first Great Council at Harrenhal
to decide the matter of succession. Fourteen
claims were considered, including the claims
of Rhaenys and her children. Rhaenys's uncle,
Lord Boremund Baratheon, was outspoken in
supporting the claims of Rhaenys and her son
Laenor during the Great Council, and Lord
Ellard Stark gave his support to Rhaenys and
Corlys as well. Other supporters included
House Dustin of Barrowton and House Manderly
of White Harbor. Yet the claims of Rhaenys
and her daughter were rejected on account
that they are females. Rhaenys and Corlys
used their wealth and influence to persuade
the lords present to vote for their son Laenor,
one of the two primary claimants. For this
they received support from Lord Boremund,
Lord Ellard, Lord Manderly, Lord Dustin, Lord
Blackwood, Lord Bar Emmon, Lord Celtigar,
as well as others. However, Laenor was eventually
passed over in favor of Baelon's son Viserys.
While the vote was kept secret, it was rumored
the assembled lords favored Viserys by twenty
to one.
For having been passed over in the line of
succession once again,
the court jester Mushroom would name her "The
Queen Who Never Was".
Following the death of Queen Aemma Arryn,
in 105 AC, Grand Maester Runciter suggested
to King Viserys I Targaryen that he shall
take Rhaenys's twelve-year-old daughter, Laena,
to wife.
King Viserys, however, chose Alicent Hightower.
Angered by the third time she and her family
had been scorned by House Targaryen, Rhaenys
and her family did not attend the royal wedding
in 106 AC.
In 113 AC, King Viserys I and his small council
began discussions concerning a betrothal for
Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen, Viserys's heir.
They eventually agreed on Rhaenys's son, Laenor.
Rhaenyra and Laenor were wed the next year.
Rhaenys's daughter Laena was married to Daemon
Targaryen, the Rogue Prince. Both of Rhaenys's
children died in 120 AC; Laena died in childbirth
during the early days of the year, while Laenor
was killed by Ser Qarl Correy while attending
a fair in Spicetown.
When the Dance of the Dragons began in 129
AC, Princess Rhaenys sat on the black council
of Queen Rhaenyra Targaryen, the daughter
of the late King Viserys I Targaryen. When
the Velaryon fleet closed off the Gullet,
sailing forth from Dragonstone and Driftmark
to block all shipping for Blackwater Bay,
the blacks' plan was for Rhaenys to fly overhead
on Meleys to keep the greens from attacking
their ships with dragons. When news arrived
on Dragonstone about the death of Lucerys
Velaryon at the hands of Prince Aemond Targaryen,
Rhaenys and her husband prevented Lucerys's
brother Joffrey from mounting his dragon to
avenge his brother. Grief-stricken following
the death of Lucerys, Queen Rhaenyra Targaryen
gave Rhaenys and Corlys command over her war
council. When Rook's Rest was attacked by
Ser Criston Cole and the Greens, as Aegon
II's supporters were called, Rhaenyra sent
her aunt to burn the army and save the fort.
Mounted on her dragon, Meleys, Rhaenys unexpectedly
turned up at Rook's Rest and laid waste to
the enemy army. However, Rhaenys was flying
into a trap.
Her nephew Aemond Targaryen confronted her
on his monstrous dragon Vhagar, the last of
the original three Targaryen dragons that
conquered Westeros, along with the King himself,
on his magnificent dragon Sunfyre. Despite
being outnumbered, Rhaenys did not flee.
Rhaenys turned to meet the attack, despite
the knowledge that Meleys stood no chance
against the two dragons. Meleys's flame faced
Vhagar's and Sunfyre's, until it looked like
that there was a second sun in the sky. The
three dragons attacked each other and fell
to the ground, entangled.
By the time the fight was over, Aemond and
Vhagar were the only ones uninjured,
while Aegon had to have a constant dose of
milk of the poppy to survive
and Sunfyre (who laid on top of Aegon) was
wounded, and a wing almost completely torn
off. It was crippled and would never fly again.
Meleys had been "torn to shreds" and Rhaenys
was just ash and bone.
That was Rhaenys's brave last stand where
she died for Rhaenyra's cause.
Rhaenys's husband Corlys, the Sea Snake, was
enraged that Rhaenyra had sent his wife Rhaenys
to the battle alone rather than going herself
or ordering her sons to accompany Rhaenys.
"Beloved daughter of Lady Jocelyn Baratheon
and Prince Aemon Targaryen, faithful wife
of Lord Corlys Velaryon, mother and grandmother,
the Queen Who Never Was lived fearlessly,
and died amidst blood and fire. She was fifty-five
years old." - is how Gyldayn describes her
in Fire And Blood.
Rhaenys Targaryen will definitely be one of
my favorite characters in the House of the
Dragon, fierce and smart woman, brave and
loyal. Honorable woman who upholds her oath
to Queen Rhaenyra and who fought for her cause
so fiercefully that not even Vhagar and Sunfyre
combined could fear her away.
Legendary characters such as Rhaenys Targaryen,
legendary battles such as the siege of Rook's
Rest in which Rhaenys flew her dragon, the
Red Queen, straight into Aegon and Aemond
despite being outnumbered by their two dragons
out of which one was mighty Vhagar. Rhaenys
could have fled, but she chose to fight and
went down in epic battle, in fire and blood.
All of that and more this Game of Thrones
prequel show, House of the Dragon, brings
in 2022.
Thank you so much for watching, hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did make sure to give
it a big thumbs up and I hope to see you in
the next one, peace!